[Musique]
le grand tout à fait avant l'apocalypse
il eut la génèse et si vous étiez là le
20 février 1986 alors vous avez vu ça
premier générique première émission
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
sommes très très heureux de vous
souhaiter la bienvenue sur l'a5
merci d'avoir allumé votre téléviseur
merci d'avoir ouvert votre maison et
nous l'espérons votre coeur à la simple
l'a5 c'est un choix supplémentaire
un choix qui existe là maintenant depuis
quelques secondes
je suis heureux de déclarer
officiellement ouvert l'a5 bonne chance
à sac la 5
ça va être super à 5 c'est classieux
de 7,5 la 15 personnes travaillent
encore aujourd'hui sur la chaîne en 1987
il y eu la cohabitation placé n c est là
une réattribution de la chaîne au tandem
hersant berlusconi l'a5 garde le même
look
[Musique]
ce fut alors le temps des stars d'un
jour sébastien collaro sabatier tous les
vendredis patrick sabatier
c'est sur la salle
mais la vraie nouveauté de cette
deuxième 5 c'est l'information création
d'une rédaction et le 14 septembre 1987
premier journal générique inoubliable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonjour
merci d'avoir choisi les informations de
la 5é lui 1670 journaux à 13h 1671 à 20
heures il eut aussi le matin le
permanent le 19 heures et le minuit pile
merci d'avoir suivi ce premier journal
de l'a5 j'espère que c'est une longue
entreprise de fidélité qui commence
entre vous et nous à 20 heures marie
france cuba da pour le journal de 20h
bones après midi merci ce sera pas
l'info connaîtra en effet d'autres
succès les programmes un peu moins
changement de slogans
[Musique]
cinéma ou télévision l'a5 tous les soirs
un film
ainsi vécu là 5 jusqu'en octobre 90
accablée par les déficits
robert hersant jette l'épongé remplacé
par le groupe hachette
il est alors des phrases qui restent moi
je dis que hachette et ses associés vont
sauver la 5
hachette et ambitieux 22 émissions
nouvelles seront mises à l'antenne des
émissions quotidiennes
que vous a présenté commence le 2 avril
les trois quarts de ces programmes
seront arrêtés au bout de quelques jours
quelques semaines ou quelques mois
le public ne répond pas présent dans le
même temps la chaîne change de look jean
paul goude passe par là
ainsi vécu là 5 jusqu'au 17 décembre 91
mesdames messieurs bonsoir bonsoir pour
nous et pour vous qui est fidèle à la 5
ce 17 décembre est une journée
particulière ce jeu alors ce fut le
début de la lutte de la lutte finale
voilà dans quelques secondes dont
quelques dizaines de secondes l'a5 va
mourir je vous rappelle que le combat ne
fait que recommencer et que dans les
kiosques dès la semaine prochaine vous
trouverez 5 plus qui sera l'organe de
liaison avec vous les téléspectateurs
patrice oui au début de cette émission
début de cette veillée qui nous a
rassemblé qui vous a rassemblé j'ai
parlé de tristesse et de fierté à propos
de fierté je voudrais simplement avant
que cette chaîne ne meure rendre un
hommage particulier au sang froid à la
dignité au sens des responsabilités et
au panache on l'a vu ce soir avec
lesquels l'ensemble du personnel et la
rédaction bien sûr on travaillait depuis
la mi-décembre depuis que les
difficultés que vous connaissez ont
commencé je voulais rendre cet hommage
je crois que c'était utile à l'ensemble
du personnel
merci bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
moi
[Musique]
point